Pierre Palmade il ne doit plus jamais
faire rire de sa vie je suis désolé
j'espère qu'il ne fera plus le spectacle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour monsieur alors moi c'est pas
monsieur c'est madame vous êtes un
monsieur non c'est on a reconnu
peut-être un garçon parce que tu avais
la voix dis-moi d'abord ton prénom avant
de me dire ce que je suis donc moi je
vais à Monsieur oui toi tu es quoi
pourquoi parce que vous pensez que je
suis une femme
qui n'ont rien demandé et qui
probablement à l'orage ne savent pas ce
qu'ils font là on les met face à des
drag queen pour soi-disant les éduquer
et pardon mais éduquer c'est pas ça les
éduquer c'est apprendre à lire apprendre
à écrire tout est malaisant évidemment
toutes les questions sont soufflées donc
il y a rien de spontané les seules
réactions spontanées chez les enfants
dans cette vidéo sont des réactions de
ah c'est bizarre pourquoi je suis là etc
donc c'est consternant c'est débile ça
ne sert à rien
pourquoi ça sert à rien demander des
enfants ça sert à quoi Mathieu de faire
ça ça ne sert à rien à part surfer sur
une base
ça détruit les repères des enfants les
enfants pour grandir ils ont besoin de
repères et ensuite quand ils sont iront
équipé à un âge où ils sont équipés pour
comprendre on leur apprend là tout de
suite parce qu'on a pas montré le reste
de la vidéo la la dame habillée en homme
commence à parler de ses relations
sexuelles et qu'elle a un partenaire qui
est homme et aussi d'autres partenaires
femmes c'est extrêmement choquant à des
enfants qui ont 5 6 et 7 ans qui ont
l'âge de mes enfants je suis désolé déjà
les parents sont au courant que leurs
enfants
ensuite je trouve que c'est pas la qu'on
foute la paix aux enfants que je
connaissais pas le métier que vous
faites OK et ça te fait envie
et ces gamins là justement quand ils
auront 10-15 ans ne Jarro pas de pierre
aux autres n'agresse pas il y aura pas
d'homophobie il y aura pas de misogynie
il y aura pas de racisme parce qu'entre
0 et 7 ans on leur a expliqué que la
différence c'est pas mieux au moins bien
c'est la différence alors quand
j'entends les mots que j'ai entendus toi
toi vous dites ça ne m'en parlant quand
je vois on leur montre ça c'est pas ça
c'est une personne humaine dans la
tolérance c'est entre 0 et 7 ans c'est
le moment où l'enfant peut tout
apprendre
ce n'est pas un âge pour qu'on les mette
face à à différents types de sexualité
et à la sexualité tout court laissez les
gamins tranquilles parce que c'est moi
qui va venir transexuel parce qu'il
avait la preuve à la fin il y a même une
incitation c'est est-ce que tu as envie
de devenir drag queen toi aussi mais
pourquoi on leur pose ces questions
pourquoi
franchement il y a du chemin à faire
quand je vous entends vous confondez
tolérance et prosélytisme c'est pas
du prosélytisme c'est pour venir en
doctriner c'est pour venir implanter
drag queen
il y a 40 ans bébé et alors et alors le
monde change il le monde change ils
iront chercher la tolérance c'est
quelque chose de général c'est un état
d'esprit
toutes les catégories de gens pour que
les gens c'est un état d'esprit mais
c'est pas désolé c'est important oui à
89 % réponse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui déclare que permanent est déjà mort
selon lui c'est le soutien du jour
regardez le lynchage médiatique on lèche
on lâche et on lâche on lâche et tu sais
pas pourquoi un exemple concret c'est
pas le même je t'ai déjà mort avant le
moindre français tu vois pas le match
ils prennent une voiture sous l'emprise
de substance illicite c'est très mauvais
bien sûr mais c'est pas à moi le juger
lié à toi il y a des procès il y a des
juges il y a des toute la machine
judiciaire pour j'ai envie de l'aider
tellement il est lâché
alors oui mais c'est pas très mauvais il
dit c'est très mauvais d'avoir pris une
voiture c'est criminel délictuel honteux
scandaleux il y a des victimes il y a un
bébé qui est né quelques minutes puis
qui est mort il y a une poursuite pour
homicide involontaire on peut pas dire
comme ça il est lynché comme à la ville
et là c'est très clair Pierre Palmade il
a pris de la drogue il a conduit en
ayant pris de la drogue il a décimé une
famille il a bousillé une famille pardon
mais qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fout qu'il y a
un âge médiatique le lynchage il va
durer aller quelques semaines quelques
mois parce que ça intéresse les gens
après ce sera terminé par contre oui
dans un an deux ans on en parlera plus
par contre pour la famille les séquelles
elles sont à vie donc on est qui a un
lynchage médiatique autour de palmates
qui est coupable c'est avéré on s'en
fout pardon on s'en fout aujourd'hui si
tu es une célébrité de toute manière
maintenant c'est les États-Unis à partir
du moment où tu es tu es mis en lumière
là-dessus c'est fini t'es condamné c'est
terminé le procès n'existera même pas
que tu gagnes tu perdes c'est fini pour
toi c'est ce que je voulais dire ce cas
est horrible évidemment je compare pas
d'autres choses mais une célébrité
aujourd'hui à partir du moment où on a
dit son nom c'est terminé les filles
sont là ils sont
un bébé qui est mort qu'est-ce que tu
veux faire on va pas pleurer pour lui
parce qu'il est connu et qu'on parle de
lui plus qu'un anonyme ça c'est des
actions sexuels c'est difficile de
prouver les faits là les filles sont
prouver établis ils la même reconnu
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire ne pas en
parler maintenant il sera jugé
effectivement on verra si la justice le
condamné comment elle le condamne mais
on doit pouvoir en parler on doit
pouvoir s'exprimer sur ces sujets et
effectivement par rapport à la famille
c'est un scandale pour moi qui soit qui
soit relâché effectivement une fois
qu'il aura payé sa dette si voilà si
tenté que ce soit évidemment possible
s'il était bouché architecte ou je sais
pas électricien il pourrait refaire son
travail lui Pierre Palmade il est
condamné à vie c'est vrai que le
lynchage médiatique a été très violent
mais moi je pense comme Béatrice je
pense que ça sert aussi de lanceur
d'alerte si ce fait divers ici quand on
a parlé on est regardé par les jeunes ça
permet un jeune de pas prendre de la
commune pas prendre son scooter après
avoir pris de la coke ou taper des
drogues des choses comme ça et ben moi
je trouve que il faut en parler et voilà
même si il est aussi le le cobaye de
cette histoire et ben c'est pas grave je
trouve que c'est très important d'en
parler parce que c'est un fait divers
qui peut faire aussi bouger les choses
et pardon il y a d'autres métiers qui
est connu que tu Maurice peut-être qui
peut se réinsérer professionnellement
d'ailleurs effectivement mais pourquoi
pas
autre chose car Palmade il ne doit plus
jamais faire rire de sa vie je suis
désolé j'espère qu'il ne fera plus le
spectacle je ne vois pas comment un jour
même dans 10 ans 20 ans il peut de
nouveau faire rire on est d'accord c'est
possible et c'est normal et c'est normal
vous êtes d'accord il est déjà mort si
sous-entend qu'il ne pourra plus faire
rire là-dessus je suis d'accord avec lui
[Musique]
s'est fait un nom dans le milieu du
grand banditisme marseillais celui que
tout le monde surnomme le dernier par un
Marseillais la femme de Jacky le Matt le
parrain des parrain s'exprime ce soir
dans TPMP
[Musique]
ce policier cet ancien policier des
froquets on va dire se fait tuer il
décide de le venger et il tue des frais
à guérillés et ça fait basculer
exactement
et vous vous aviez Mathieu je fais le
calcul de 28
c'est ça c'est ça quand vous quand vous
l'avez rencontré au départ vous n'avez
pas demandé ce qu'il faisait dans la vie
avec les cheveux blancs
vous avez eu peut-être un jour peur de
lui sachant ce qu'il était capable de
faire dans d'autres circonstances une
fois chez le père c'est une bonne
question
parce que je
je voulais le quitter
s'est passé c'était au Maroc pourquoi
parce qu'il me trompait
et après vous êtes remis ensemble non
vous avez dit c'était terminé vous
l'avez vous l'avez cramé comment il
avait oublié son téléphone
[Musique]
il y a quelques minutes dans la presse
Pierre Palmade a été libéré de sa
détention provisoire il y a plus d'une
semaine la cour d'appel de Paris avait
décidé de l'envoyer en prison il n'ira
finalement pas en tout cas pas pour le
moment le juge d'instruction a pris la
décision là il y a quelques minutes de
lever la détention provisoire et donc
symboliquement de remettre en liberté
Pierre Palmade aujourd'hui pour raison
médicale ça veut dire proprement noter
les spectateurs pour moi qui pour raison
médicale c'est ça veut dire quoi il est
libre là ça veut dire quoi alors il est
libre il est libre pour l'instant il est
il est hospitalisé donc de toute façon
il va passer il va pas aller loin bien
sûr mais techniquement si il était guéri
et sur pied il pourrait sortir de
l'hôpital et rentrer chez lui et là le
parquet de Melun qui est à l'origine
avait demandé la détention de Pierre
Palmade alors là c'est plus c'est
justement il a pas fait appel il a fait
un référé des tensions alors qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'ils
veulent remettre en prison qui depuis le
début
pense que Pierre Palma doit être en
détention ne cède pas une nouvelle fois
le procureur revient à la charge et dit
non je conteste et donc il y aura une
décision très rapide dans les quelques
jours je crois que c'est 48 heures voilà
pour regarder avec Valérie 48 heures
pour savoir si effectivement c'est la
juge d'instruction ou le procureur qui
entre guillemets l'emporte dans cette
étape écroué à libérer
en prison on est dans une histoire ça
pourrait être un sketch si c'était pas
aussi grave
d'une espèce de petite guéguerre entre
le parquet et le juge instruction là
tout de suite la juge d'instruction a
levé la mesure de de
détention d'accord voilà regardez
Valérie on se demandait si l'appel qui a
été
suspensive de la décision
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un côté
provisoire même dans l'exécution de la
décision de la juge d'instruction
parce qu'il y a énormément parce que là
énormément de gens qui réagissent là sur
les sur les réseaux et qui disent que
c'est inadmissible qui soit libre voilà
ou quoi mais décision définitive je
pense dans les 48 heures c'est ça
examiner quatre jours en 4 jours voilà
donc si vendredi il est libre qu'il est
plus qui doit plus être à l'hôpital il
rentre chez nous oui parce que le
procureur
satisfaction une fois il est pas du tout
ça qu'il obtienne satisfaction deux fois
et sans doute faudra-t-il trouver un
lieu où il pourra continuer son
processus de soins à voir si c'est dans
un cadre médical aussi chez lui et jugé
propice
ça c'est pas obligé ça veut dire qu'il
peut il veut le juge il peut dire il
peut rentrer chez lui et puis on verra
après ou pas du tout mais je peux
décider le juge peut décider de dire il
n'y a plus de raison de le maintenir
dans un milieu syndicalisé traduit en
langage de la vie quotidienne des gens
c'est Palma des livres après tout ce
qu'il a fait donc ça pose quand même
énormément de questions
il a pas été condamné la détention
préventive
elle est pas obligatoire
[Musique]
un moment très fort du chaud c'est
dommage qu'on rendait tous les artistes
à une des figures du groupe c'est Mimie
Mathy
[Musique]
je vais faire une petite réunion et il y
avait une espèce de caisse de
ravitaillement secours moi qui me
convenait moyennement donc c'est pour ça
que qui a compris
les restos gardaient donc de l'argent
donc c'était
pour moi je voulais suivre ce qui avait
fait et Coluche Coluche quand il y a eu
de l'argent entre eux à la fin il en
restait il allait voir l'abbé Pierre et
il lui a fait un chèque de 7 millions de
francs un truc comme ça faut dire on ne
garde rien de chaque saison et tout
l'argent est reversé et comme il y avait
une caisse de secours je trouvais pas ça
bien donc c'est tout j'ai rien compris
c'est un espèce de fond de roulement
une espèce de de somme d'argent
conservée pour
[Musique]
sont faits il y avait une somme qui
était conservée une somme de secours
l'année où Coluche malheureusement on
l'a fait qu'une fois a fait ça cette ce
reliquat en plus il a été directement
voir l'abbé Pierre et il lui a fait le
chèque de tout ce qui restait comme
argent
mais quelle était
le panier pour la saison suivante et tu
étais le seul à pas vouloir de cette
caisse tout le monde était ok en fait
finalement
personne ne connaissait trop l'existence
de cette cette caisse donc c'était
opaque quand même non non
j'étais inscrite mais ce qui était
inscrit c'était une histoire de ouf elle
commence pas parlé de caisse noire non
mais c'était opaque son mari
rien on donne tout voilà et moi ce qui
me gênait c'était qu'on donnait pas tout
on en gardait je retire le terme caisse
noire quand même une somme et souvent
reproche aux associations d'avoir de
trop grosses sommes en frais de
fonctionnement comme on dit souvent ça
crée des problèmes c'est ce que vous
leur reprochez hein
c'était une caisse de ravitaillement
secours
je n'étais pas d'accord voilà donc c'est
évident
on en garde pas
normalement c'est clair il y avait un
caisse voilà j'ai rien compris donc tu
peux m'expliquer s'il te plaît il y a de
l'argent qui restait à la fin dont la
somme Jean-Marie était de je n'en sais
plus rien et cet argent gent
des 40 millions de de de
centimes 400000 de centimes ah oui là
c'est énorme
moi j'ai fait réunir le conseil
d'administration
une trentaine j'ai expliqué le truc ce
qui ne me convenait pas et c'est tout il
y avait Jean-Jacques et il y avait tous
les représentants de de l'association
[Musique]
Roger de quoi souffre Florent Pagny
alors il souffre d'un cancer du poumon
c'est une affection malheureusement
assez fréquente chez les fumeurs et
devait subir une immunothérapie qui est
la fonction actuellement de
thérapeutique la plus la plus évoluée
qui donne d'excellents résultats et puis
bon pour des raisons XYZ il a un petit
peu décalé
et se trouve que là il a découvert
l'apparition
dans dans une petite d'un ganglion on va
dire ça comme ça il est où actuellement
Florent Pagny alors pour le moment on le
sait pas moi j'étais personnellement
assez gêné en fait par le reportage
d'hier parce que
il faut quand même prendre un peu de
recul nous se reportage a fait paniquer
beaucoup beaucoup de gens bien sûr à la
radio le matin moi on a reçu énormément
de messages de fans qui se sont
inquiétés pour pour Florent Pagny les
résultats il est connaît et que si les
résultats étaient si mauvais que ça il
aurait annulé ces dates de concert déjà
donc moi c'est la première chose qui
qu'il a passé six mois en Patagonie il
suivait le traitement là-bas absolument
alors il suivait plus du tout maintenant
puisque effectivement le traitement
qu'il n'a pas voulu suivre comme vient
de le dire le docteur c'est un cette
immunothérapie qui ne l'a pas voulu
suivre à Paris pour retourner en
Patagonie à la fin de sa chimiothérapie
et c'est un traitement qui visiblement
en Argentine est un peu compliqué à
suivre ce qui m'étonne en fait c'est que
Florent ne se soit pas encore prononcé
publiquement suite à la diffusion du
reportage d'hier
c'est fans je vous dis à la radio on a
reçu énormément de messages et et c'est
vrai qu'il n'a pas il ne sait pas
exprimé alors que depuis le début de sa
maladie il communiquait énormément sur
notamment sur Instagram donc on aurait
pu attendre qu'après ce reportage qui
est encore une fois été tourné il y a
près de 2 mois il s'exprime pour dire
bah voilà les examens dont j'ai pas on
les a fait et voilà ce qu'il en est il a
pas fait pour le moment et encore une
fois souvenez-vous il y a un an
lorsqu'il annonce sa maladie la première
chose qui fait c'est annuler c'est
interrompre sa tournée donc le fait que
ces concerts soient maintenus depuis
décembre depuis novembre sont maintenus
pour pour cet été peut quand même
laisser entrevoir un espoir concernant
les résultats des examens qui ont été
faits par Florent Pagny
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]